the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok so just a few quick announcements
so homework 1 is posted due Friday so
office hours shortly after class 4:30 to
5:30 in 51 1:45 so if you have any
questions you can ask her as well or you
can ask me now if you think they're okay
cool so okay so I'm gonna proceed then
so I hope so most of you I think I've
started playing in the online
tournaments I hope you guys if you
haven't I hope you plan on Saturday soon
yeah I hope they've been fun so far
ok so today I'm gonna focus more
specifically on poker itself I know last
class I talked about a lot of like
general concepts on decision making and
how we think about you know exploiting
your opponent versus playing within a
Nash equilibrium way today I'm gonna
focus mostly on poker and try to give a
lot of hand examples and I'm gonna
introduce a post spot plate which I
didn't really talk about last time so so
basically what happens after you see the
file ok so I'm gonna just start with an
example so we get a screen off suit in
hijack -1 so I think I called it LoJack
in an earlier slide in last class but
basically it's it's a 4 away from the
button so it's how many people the thing
that matters is how many people behind
how cards and could be left to act so
we've raised we raise a bit bigger than
should point to 5 big blinds but I'm not
going to pick
for now so we're a bit deeper stack so
we want to build a bigger pot because we
think we have an advantage I guess okay
so it's folded to both blinds and both
blinds call okay so the flop comes on
nine eight juice so we we sort of missed
the box and the small blind checks and a
big box okay so what what happened is
player so far okay so now we we have a
decision here essentially so first I
want to talk about checking to the
preflop aggressive so this is sort of
this is sort of a conventional way to
play so they both check so we were the
preflop aggressor so in this case I mean
by a pre poppin dresser the person who
put in the last raised preflop and the
reason why this is significant is
because in some sense we have a stronger
range of hands than they do because we
could potentially have pocket aces which
is the best hand and it's going to be a
good hand on a pretty much any flop
whereas it's much harder it's much more
unlikely for them to have Calaca dayss
because if they have pocket aces it
would be a good play and a tempting play
to re-raise preflop so basically they're
sort of just recognizing the fact that
you know on average we're gonna have a
better hand in them so they're gonna
check to us and let us bet because in
general on average they would prefer if
the pot was smaller and we would prefer
if the pot is bigger because our range
is better so yeah so they be they both
check to us and right so like like let's
say they had a pretty good handling
let's say small blank had 10 9 10 9
suited or something which is the top
hair so the highest pair on this floor
that's a pretty good hand but that's
still a hand that loses two pocket aces
and there's still the risk if he bets
out with 10 9 we could just raise and
then he has to be worried you know do we
have pocket aces there's basically
always gonna be this worry of pocket
aces and pocket kings and just big pairs
that actually where do you note that we
have to worry about less occasionally
someone there probably should slow play
pocket aces creep up and just call but
most of the time it'll be
idea for them to rebase to get more
money in preflop so that's why they both
check to us so now we have the
opportunity to bet already check back so
let me first like what how big do that
if we decide to bet so here we bet 200
into 375 which is about half the pot and
so between betting big and betting small
it's sort of the same principles I
talked about last class between raising
big and raising small prefault
so the advantage is betting small so the
disadvantage of betting small is that
you give your opponent better odds to
call so like let's say they have I don't
know like jack 10 here I can that's
losing to you they have they have a
better odds to call and a cheaper price
to call to see another card to try to be
you but on the other hand you know our
hand isn't amazing our hand isn't good
here essentially we've missed the [ __ ]
we have impaired our hand and if we get
raised we're probably going to have to
fold and the more we bet the more we
lose when we get raised so it's the same
sweet slot principles if you bet too
small you get called too often by worse
hands that can just have good odds to
talk and if you bet too big you're just
losing a lot when you get raised so a
good rule of thumb is to bet half the
pot on the flop and then like a slightly
bigger percentage on the term like 60%
and then an even bigger percentage on
the on the river like 70% or something
something like that is about reasonable
you can bet up to like a hundred percent
of five on the river so I say just
somewhere between fifty to a hundred
percent of pot is a good amount to bet
and the fraction should increase as you
get closer to the river so this might
seem slightly contradictory because what
I said last class was you were able the
last class I said you want to give your
opponent you don't want to give your
opponent great odds but in some sense if
we get to the river right all the cards
have come out there's a there's no more
unknown cards so either they have the
better hand or we have the better hand
but there's it's there's gonna be no
uncertainty in what cards could still
come so in some sense you might think
it's more intuitive to bet smaller on
the turn and River
and bigger on the flop [ __ ] on the
flop they have more chances to to out
drawers where it's under turning river
we have they have here to let me just
find stand there okay so so this might
seem contradictory right so I'm saying
that bigger on the river but on the
river they actually have in some sense
there's on the river there's the it's
more determined whether their hand is
good or not so why is this why do we
want it that bigger on the turn then the
flop where is on the flop any hand sort
of has closer to fifty percent equity
because anything can so happen with two
parties to come so the main reason is
because when you bet the flop
they're not just deciding to call your
flop bet for the equity there they also
potentially have to call a turn bet and
a river bet and essentially this factor
the fact that they have to you can
threaten to bet again on the turn and
bet again on the river and they have to
call all these bats is a bigger factor
than the fact that they have there's
slightly better odds to call on the
phone okay so another important thing to
say when I say bet 50 between 50 to 100
percent of the pot I mean I think that's
it's very important to bet at least some
fractions of the pot especially when
they're checking G because in some sense
betting small is strictly worse than
checking like in this case you've got 50
which I guess isn't nothing but imagine
you bet $1 so the issue with this is the
rules of betting safe right if anyone
gets any positive amount then the guys
who checked now have a chance to check
rates so if you're betting small which
is almost the same as checking all
you're doing is giving your opponent a
free option you're you're allowing them
the opportunity to say okay you know I
could have just like if you check you
see the term and the term cops but by
betting now they have the opportunity a
second chance you bet yeah how does this
change I have like nuts should you bet
you want cause at that point right
reverie yeah so I'm gonna get to that
yes so if you have a good hand yeah
you'll know that - because you want
cause um right now I'm just talking
about a general strategy to play with
your entire
and in general I guess that's how I'm
trying to encourage people to think
about poker in this class like instead
of thinking about what cards do I have
and what cards do my opponent have we I
try to talk in terms of what is the
probability distribution over my
opponents hands and what's the
probability distribution over my hands
in his essentially so I'm just talking
about a general scenario okay cool so
right so with you you never went about
two small basically it's better to just
not that there's no point to bet really
small because you're giving away a free
option okay so yeah so this is this is
what I just said essentially because
remember just because the chest doesn't
mean they have bad hands they're often
checking regardless for the reasons I
described earlier okay so in this
situation with ace-queen offsuit I think
both betting 200 and checking are
reasonable place and let's analyze the
advantages and disadvantages of both so
so the advantage of betting 200 is that
you don't give some garbage hand like
King Jack a chance to help draw you so
in this situation if we bet 200 probably
if someone had King Jack they'll
probably just fold because it's a it's
almost one of the worst hands on this on
this board and if we bet 200 then
they're gonna fold and then we could
just win the pot right there if we don't
bet maybe they turn oh come the king or
reject and they can beat us so what's
the advantage of checking the advantage
of checking is we get to see the term
card for sure we can't get check for
these like right now if we bet then we
get check for these we probably have to
fold with no pair but if we check we
might see a queen or an ace on the
turtle should be great and another
advantage of checking is in some sense
when you bet in this spot you're only
called by hands that beat you you know
you're gonna get King Jack to fold which
is still fine because they have a six
outs but you are ahead of them so it's
not the it's not the end of the world to
just check in you know if the term comes
like a deuce you're still ahead and it
checks all the way to showdown like all
the
to the point where you have to flip over
your cards you're still gonna beat King
Jack whereas whereas when you bet you're
essentially getting all the answer ahead
of to fold like if they have a seven
which are also ahead of they're probably
gonna fold and pretty much all the hands
that beat you you're probably aren't
gonna fold like maybe some of the fold
pocket threes or something but for the
most part you're gonna get called by
nine you're gonna get called by an eight
so it's this idea of like sort of
adverse selection you're you're get
you're getting called only by hands that
beat you and you're just holding out or
anything else so overall I took needs
about balance out and you can I think
betting or checking is are both fine
okay so now let's suppose it's the same
spot and we had king and queen we had
king queen instead of a screen so
pretend all the action was the same all
the preflop action the flop action
everything was the same except just our
cards changed so in this case if we do
the same comparison again well see that
betting has a bigger advantage now
because we can get hands like ace Jack
and e7 to fold those hands previously
when you're dealing with ace Queen but
now we don't want to risk getting a
situation where it's checks to show down
and everyone flips over their cards and
we lose through these chakras so so I'd
say in this case now with king queen
instead of ace queen betting has a lot
more advantage because we're getting
better hands to full okay and this is
what you're talking about yeah what if
you have done that so in this case if
it's so suppose now we change our came
to a queen so we actually haven't really
left hand we have pocket queens which is
a tollbooth head or a pair of blood and
incredible on the flop so now let's look
at the advantages of embedding versus
checking so now the one advantage of
betting that we never had before because
we all have we always had bad hands is
now we can get worse hands to call us if
they have ten nine or eight eight or
pocket fives they're probably going to
call and we're beating them so we're
just going to win more money and the
advantage of checking is essentially
none so the correct play I think is
clearly to bet in this situation so
essentially what I'm trying to get at is
so I call this the fundamental theorem
of poker it's sort of a made-up term but
essentially so one of the one of the
main things
realize when you're just betting
post-flop is the bet basically
accomplishes one of two things so with
your good hands you wanted that because
you can get them to call which worse but
still good hands and we call this value
betting so with the pocket means this is
what you're doing is down betting when
you when do you bet and then with the
bottom hands in your range you should
bet to get them to fold better but still
pretty weak hands so in this case when
we had King Queen we would be we would
be betting you got them two full days
jack so this is called bluffing so
essentially the point of a bet should
either be a value bet because you have a
really good hand or a bluff because you
have a really bad and you want to sort
of think in terms of that way and you
know if you if you ever find yourself
making a bet and you're not sure whether
it's a value bet or a bluff then chances
are you may you shouldn't be better so
with the middle hands in your range you
should check because if you bet you fold
out all the weaker hands and you keep it
on the stronger it's okay action so this
is like the fundamental concept in poker
essentially on that we should try to
realize okay so I I sort of made this
diagram so the best hands are at the top
of the rectangle is the worst surgeon
with the worst hands are at the bottom
so once again we're thinking in terms of
our entire range of possibilities so
post flop we want to sort of so that's
on the left post flop we want to bet the
best hands Bluff the worst hands and
then check things in the middle and then
the preflop basically we fold all the
bad hands and then we we raise or if
someone's already basically re-raise the
best hands and we just raise the pretty
good hands I'll talk more about people
in a future lecture but I just wanted to
contrast this because I don't want
someone you think you know if I have 72
offsuit preflop I should be bluffing
because it's a different scenario
because preflop you're choosing what
percentage of hands to play and it's
strictly better to just choose the best
30% for the best 40% instead of choosing
the best 10% in the worst
okay so so going back to this principle
one seven seven so it's a still the same
situation so I'm analyzing the same
situation many many times it's different
with seven seven the right play is
definitely to check because I so with
ace-queen it sits in a similar spot
duties Queen and that is also you get
called only by better hands and you've
mostly only fold out worse hands but
with ace Queen at least there was the
advantage that if they called with like
an eight or a nine we could turn we have
more chances to beat them we could turn
an Ace or a queen and win more money or
alternatively we could like turn a jack
which gives us a straight draw and try
to bluff them off there or something
where is this pocket sevens there's less
room to play so I think with pocket
sevens you should definitely check out
this fall okay so some other stuff about
continuation betting on flops um I
wouldn't Bluff super-scary
flops by super-scary I essentially
mathematically it just means there's
there's a lot of uncertainty because so
many things are possible and it
basically this happens when there's
three cards of the same suit and they're
all connected
so whenever the board is like this you
know it looks scary it looks very
coordinated but mathematically speaking
it's essentially saying anything can
happen and no one should fold if you
have anything at all because you know if
you have any ten you have a chance of
making it straight if you have a
reasonable heart you have a chance of
making a flush just any hand is gonna
have a reasonable chance same as you
know if you even if you have like an ace
like I guess as we do you have a chance
of turning a higher pair so I would just
check and basically give up on this on
this lock or check and hope you hit an
ace you're a queen that yes and another
thing is continuation betting into too
many people if you have nothing it can
be an advanced play in certain
situations if everyone else also
recognizes that you know if your
continuation betting in d5 people you
must have such a good hand that they're
gonna hold fold a hand is gonna say left
pocket easier but for the most part in
practice
I would say if the pot has like six or
seven people I wouldn't try to bet on
the flop with over cards to try to get
everybody folds because someone's gonna
have to or itself or someone's gonna
have a seven someone's gonna have a pair
okay so so I talked about sort of one
you want a bet post it up so now I'll
talk a bit more about when you wanna
call bets possible and I'm gonna try to
give a lot of different situations so
now let's look at calling bets and I
think newer players especially tend to
call with and weaker then then you need
to so the general rule of thumb is
unless your opponent bets extremely
small which they should not do by what I
explained you should fold most of your
hands to a half pot bet so in some sense
most hands missed mismo swaps and when
you miss there's really not a reason to
do anything other than it full there's a
lot of tournaments again I always play
the next tournament and get dealt a new
hand and try to have a good hand so okay
so okay so now I'm going to change the
situation up a bit but once again I'm
going to analyze the same betting
situation over different hands so now
it's everyone folds to is folds to the
button we're still 40 bets deep because
the blinds are played by 50 and we have
we have 2000 and so the button makes it
125 and we decide to call with our hand
okay so so let's say we have 29 suited
in this case and okay let's say the flop
is 1072 so we check we check as a form
of respect to the preflop razor and then
they vent half pot so here this is a
situational order you know we've got no
pair no draw I guess we have an over
card we have an overturned in the queen
and we can turn a pair of Queens to -
pair of tens but that's only three cards
that help us basically the correct play
is just a fool do you essentially have
nothing here you know you have some like
speculative straight draws where if you
hit a jack and then innately
two cards that come for you then go
straight but for the most part we've got
nothing we just fold here are some other
situations where you should just fold so
here we have East High but the board has
three pretty big cards and there's a
decent chance he's gonna have one of
them and if he doesn't he's gonna have
like Queen China ten nine or something
with straight or some kind of straight
draw with a lot of outs so there's just
no reason to play hands like these so
it's totally fine if you if you lose a
lot of hands as long as you win more
chips on the hands that you do win so
just fold this not much reason to play
here you have this this board is a bit
better for a union of East nine high on
a six high board but there's a lot of
straight draws and there is a cluster on
a stage Buster on this floor itself I
would still fold here we even have a
pair but this is an example where I
think I'd fold even though you have a
pair so we have we have a pair of nines
here which is decent but once again
there's three hearts and it's easy for
him to make a flush or maybe straight
and even if he doesn't we're gonna be
we're gonna have to check check get him
on the term checking him on the river
and then they can bet and we have to
decide whether we call or not so just
overall there's there's a lot of and
this is why what I'm talking about about
being out of position so we're we have
to go out first on every street so it's
going to be tougher to make good
decisions okay so now we're getting some
better hands but I think I would
advocate still holding these so here are
hands it's not bad
we've got we basically got a four out
straight draw which is usually called a
gun shot you need to hit an eight to
Turnus tree and also we've got diamonds
if we if we hit two diamonds in a row
and make a flush but over on this spot I
would still fold just because we even
though we've got four outs to our gun
shot we've got no combinations we've got
no other combinations to help us like a
nine is essentially useless when there's
hi-oh serves on the board turning in
nine disabilities at all turning seven
doesn't help us at all and furthermore
even if we turn in me it's possible so
if we turn eight then Queen Dahlia makes
a better Street than us and also King
Queen which already has a straight is a
better straight than us so even when we
hit it it's not even we're not even a
hundred percent sure we're gonna win the
hand and we could just put our chips and
after hitting any and lose all our chips
so I would fold this as well for a
gutshot is pretty bad unless you have
other stuff to go with it okay so in
this case we have a better straight job
so in this case we have an e headed
straight draw
because an eight gives us a straight
eats routine but a king also gives gives
us a straight we have 93 King but in
this case I would still I would still
recommend folding just because if the
King comes then you know who you have a
straight but we lose your enemies so 10
Jack Queen King ace is going to just be
a higher rate than our 930 King straight
so even though we have a lot of outs
that I would start that good and it's
possible we just once again we make a
second best hand which is the worst
possible situation in folders because
you're gonna put a lot of money in and
you're gonna lose okay so this isn't
another example I would fold pocket
fives on Queen Jack ten do you have a
small pair you started with a small pair
but you didn't improve it all the flop
did not help your hand at all and it
most likely helps your opponent's hand
okay so okay so here's a question you
can ask so and all these spots I say
fold but what if I think Bluff raising
will work you know what if I think I can
get him to fold if I raise so so what I
want to what I want to say is when
you're bluffing on the flop it's usually
because you have some kind of draw or
some kind of nice speculative hand that
has a chance of turning in you a good
hand and all the examples I showed not
only our hands bad there's not that many
good cards for us with the exception of
maybe the seven nine and
if you turn it's pretty good but yeah
even this even this thing if you turn
any it's not that good because the board
is then going to be I ate ten Jack Queen
so we're only playing with a one card
Street which is still fairly easy to put
us on okay so before I get to spots
where maybe we want to raise potentially
bluff raise let me just go to school
through some software I think calling is
a pretty good play so here I think
calling with a sign hi on this Florida's
reasonable and in the example where I
said he should fold the block was six
five four on and alissa flash drum so
they were straight drives and flush
drops in this case the board is paired
which really helps us because there's
just fewer combinations of pairs that he
can make and a three is a pretty small
part so it's pretty unlikely they have a
three so each time height is pretty good
here you have two over cards you even
have a diamond factor flush draw so I
would call here okay so we get so
getting better here this hand is even
better we have an ace three we have
bottom pair on this pretty safe flop it
is three different partisan they could
have a jack or or five but just overall
against the range word we have
tremendous equity here so I would call
so no twice they call not rates
I'll give you examples of how good
roughly speaking our hand has to be to
raise all right so here I would call the
board is very scary but we have second
pair and I think second pair is just
second pair with the best kicker of the
ace so that's definitely good enough to
call with ace nine I think this would be
borderline whether you call I think
calling is okay but not mandatory okay
here's another example second pair on a
safer board this is a pretty good hand
I mean if they've got an ace we're not
drawing to that many outs but if they
don't have a nice they're not driving to
that many outs
so it's because whenever big curves come
on the flop like an ace and a king in
some sense even if there's rushing
straight draws more the more of who's
gonna win has been decided because if
you've got a big pair like if you've got
an Acer Akane then there's not like an
even bigger
that can come in there and beat you and
if you don't have it then you you know
it's like if you have ten nine even if
you turn it ten you're not gonna
outdrive each seven so so here I we just
call here you have a pretty good pair
pocket eights on 93 you obviously you
have a very good hand here but I just
think in this case where there is no
flush draws no straight draws there's
not really that much reason to raise
because it's not like you're gonna get
called by the worst hands that often
that I would still only call even though
in some sense your hand is very very
strong here like I would expect you you
have the better hand more than eighty
percent of the time but the problem is
when you raise that are only playing the
20% that beats which is hands with nines
hands of threes and like pocket 10s plus
so here I would also recommend calling
even though we have top hair so top pair
the highest pair on the board it's a
pair of aces which seems you know it
seems like we have a good hand we should
raise but once again our other card
which is very relevant is very slow in
this case so we're gonna lose to East
Queen and it's a big ace and furthermore
there's not that much reason to raise
because we're not that scared of letting
him see a trump card with say 10 9
because even if he turns a 10 or 9 he's
not gonna beat us so right so the reason
who raised is essentially do not let
your opponent see more cards and give
them out but they don't have that many
outs if were ahead of them
so I would so this is you can say this
is like a way ahead way behind
situations that's a terminology that you
might hear which basically means you're
either way ahead because they don't have
an ace or you're way behind because they
got these Queen and when you're way
ahead or way behind you don't really
want to be raising because he's just
gonna call you when you're way behind
and he's just gonna fall when you're way
ahead ok so here we're getting into some
pretty good hands
um East Jack I'm Jack tonight with the
flush draw I think if you raised it's
not it wouldn't be the end of the world
the issue is I think I think two
thousand chips when the blinds are only
twenty-five fifty is still a bit much to
put in your entire stack on this flop
and
just because even though you have pop
hair with the best kicker there's a lot
of streets and even if he's like even if
let's say they have like twenty nine of
hearts and that's behind a mood
currently example have a pair of nines
there's just so many so many straight
and flush outs they're gonna have that
you're not you're never really getting
it in a head of equity by that much
so I would just fall and see what the
turn is but that's maybe the best one of
the examples of the strongest hands you
can have where I would still recommend
Kali in this case we've got a small over
pair but I would still call even though
once again we have the best hand
probably 80% plus at the time but once
again when you raise your only getting
played back out by the 20% that beats
you so okay yeah so and notice there
when I went through these examples the
stack size was very important right so
from the first class the important
things are position stack sizing cards
in this case I the position was the
button the cards I've showed you what
the cards are but the stack size the
fact that you're playing for potentially
2,000 shows is very important and if
you're playing for fewer chips then you
can risk gambling a lot more as I've
shown you later okay so another note is
you could argue for check raising and
some of these call situations especially
the ones where your hand was more
vulnerable to over cards so let me just
quickly run through them again so I'll
describe what they are so this is this
is one of them because here you could
argue okay I want to raise because if I
call what if he has jack 10 then he can
he has six outs right here this is
another example what if they have 10 9
they can turn to tenor and I and beat us
here
this is not an example here I think
calling is clearly correct because the
only because the only bad cards are like
a queen because an ace gives you two
pair so it's there's just very few scary
things very the board is already scary
and there's not that many older cards
that could come this is another example
because in this case there's actually no
scary parts and so no card is there's
not no card that you're afraid of giving
him this is an example where you could
argue for raising you know you don't
want Jack tend you see
but that's reasonable yeah here there's
no risk it's completely safe so I would
never raise here here I guess there are
some bad cards but it's if you raise
there they can just call with your
drawers anyway to try to hit so here
this is an example or you know you could
argue for raising to not let them see it
turn card okay so so yeah these are
reasonable arguments and I think raising
some of these call hands would not be a
terrible plight but I think for most of
these day Pantages of callings still
outweigh the advantages the advantages
of raising especially if your opponent
is also capable bluffing because like
let's say you you check race so let's
say they make it 150 you make it 400 and
then let's say they go all-in but
they're gonna go on not only with hands
that beat you like pocket sevens plus
they'll also occasionally do this with
hands like h3 or h4 hands that have an
over card in the ACE but also have a gut
shot straight draw like h3 or h4 has um
has can can make it straight then you're
just in a very tough spot basically if
you call your you're not in a good
situation because they're often behind
but it'd be full then you're also
holding to a lot of weaker hands
so there's just a lot of ways for the
hand piggle badly P if you raise because
your hand sort of it's too it's not good
enough to raise and call if they raise
yet it's too good to sort of waste as a
check raise fluff and just like fold if
they raise right like let's say um like
let's say my plane here was pocket sixes
is to check raise and fold if they do
anything else but then like you could
argue why am I doing this with a hand as
good as pocket sixes why don't I do this
with ten nine because it's gonna be a
similar result most of the time they're
gonna either fold and I'm gonna win the
pot with ten nine or they're gonna raise
and I'm gonna have to fold with ten nine
occasionally they'll call but you could
argue in that case I would almost rather
have ten nine
sixes because a kids pocket sixes I'm
just going to always lose and ten nine
and who knows I've been charted ten so
anyway so it's all the long story short
is I would just recommend just calling
with most of those hands although
there's definitely lots of arguments you
can make forward raising yeah okay yeah
that's a good point
um so yeah I think that the main reason
is just your like overall equity against
their range is pretty low on this board
compared to an average situation if you
have a top pair top kicker like if the
board is Jack seven - you were equity
against their range is probably
something like eighty five percent what
is on this board your your equities is
overall a lot less there's a lot more
hands that'd be huge so there's there's
a lot higher probability that if you
raise in column but are the money in
that you're behind basically so there's
this little huge risk of that so the but
yeah I do agree it it does feel very
unsatisfying to only call and let them
see those cards but I think it's sort of
the lesser of two evils in this
situation between putting all your money
in with this hand versus letting them
see some parts yeah all right cool okay
so just so good does my hand have to be
raised and the question depends on the
effective stack size but when the
effective stack size is fairly deep so
let's say forty big blinds I think is
about forty big blinds or deeper so you
know you have a lot of chips you're
playing for a lot of chips relative to
the blinds you need a pretty good hand
to want to put all your money in so a
general rule of thumb is to hair or
bigger and yeah once again this is only
this is only applicable when the
effective sack size is large and a lot
of the online tournaments especially the
ones where the blinds go up quickly the
effective sack size can be around
or even lower pretty quickly oh yeah how
much do all these decisions depend on
their position or your position
okay that's a very good question
actually um right so it's so it's so in
this situation so the answer is
essentially yeah it depends a lot and
this the examples I gave are
specifically for the fun yeah so I would
say if they were under the guy that
instead of the button you need to play
you need to play somewhat differently
because they're gonna have because on
the button you know they're gonna have a
55% of hands and let's say here like 10
9 is a possibility but actually maybe a
better example is I think this is a
board word word it's really different
because against against some if they
raise from the button you know they
could have 55% of hands and each three
is a pretty good hand here but if they
raise from under the gun and they're
pretty tight and their ranges pocket
eights are better and east queenie
Stratos is king then you're doing much
worse yeah yeah so it definitely matters
a lot and yeah I mean yeah so I guess I
can't I can't go through every single
possibility right like this position
this stack size with this so so yeah so
you do have to do a bit of extrapolation
like if they're right now then this
agrees examples they're the blend if
they cut off the range is gonna be a bit
stronger um there's a hijacker angel
even stronger yeah yeah that's a very
good question yeah very very good point
yeah because in all the analysis I just
did I'm assuming their range includes
hands as bad as like eat seven suited
and stuff which isn't gonna be the case
if they were earlier position okay so
all right so how good does my hand have
to be raised so today or better but by
cheaper or better I mean two pair were
both of your cards naked hitter here
where one pairs on the flop I wouldn't
count this as two pair and you know this
two pair is complete trash because any
heart beat so I would go on here this
one is also pretty bad so okay so now
one would be things okay so so I think
this is one this is basically the best
thing that can happen to you in poker
pretty much
uh-huh oh is this exact situation so
here we got yeah we got three of a kind
and and there's also a lot of drawers so
we're gonna get playback at a decent
amount because if it hurts to have like
Queen Jack there's just so much stuff
that isn't gonna fold and we're always
gonna be way ahead pretty much always
gonna be way ahead so it's no good so
yeah I actually think this is very close
to the dream situation does anyone have
an idea why this situation is almost in
some sense even better than say we had
pocket tens exact way okay no more
playoffs today so you can see right so
it's almost even better in some sense
you have five five because as Ben said
if you have pocket fives there's there's
you can have a ten and put in a lot of
money if you have pocket tens even
though you're crushing even harder it's
almost like you've taken all the good
cards away and he's is always gonna fold
so okay here's another situation where
your hands very good although I think
you can make the case you're just
calling here yeah I don't want to say
you you have to raise because your hand
is a so invulnerable and even though the
chances that he has the remain ace and a
better card you go with it is pretty
small there's there is still a lot of I
guess like adverse selection in this
case where because there's no drawers
when you raise he will fold a lot of
stuff and the stuff that he does play
it's not going to only include the
remaining ace like he will call with
pocket sevens almost certainly but it
does include it does significantly make
his range more likely to be the ace that
we do so I think just calling is okay
here always you have the best possible
hand although once again I think just
calling as this sort of a trap is
reasonable although III would advocate
just raising I think it's the simpler
play you know calling I think you'll see
a lot of a lot of high stakes players do
as a trap but it's a very very tricky
play I think raising definitely has lots
of merits because like if they've got
King like even ace king they they're not
gonna fold they just want to get on
but because there they're probably gonna
think you're more likely to have a
single heart than two hearts so if they
have a singing especially when it's only
40 big lines they're probably just gonna
be happy putting all the money in and
before you can see a fourth heart so
like in this case even though you don't
need a fourth heart to make a flush a
fourth card is a really bad card for you
because that sort of kills all the
action you're getting from from a king
from a pair of kings okay so this is a
similar situation although in this case
I would say a flush raises mandatory in
the previous case I think it's not
mandatory because your hand is so safe
wait here if you decide to try to trap
your opponent
there's you'll never like end up
trapping yourself what is it here if you
just have any heart higher than a six if
a fourth card comes they're beating you
now and worst of all is you know let's
say they have ten of Hearts nine of
diamonds if you raise you could have
easily gotten them to fold that ten of
hurts probably other that 10 or 10 of
diamonds is a bit good let's say like 95
say Baggins there they almost certainly
would have folded their higher part and
now you just lost an entire pot because
you didn't raise so here I would raise
you have a straight you are drawing dead
if they have a flush but with only 40
big blinds I think those chances of the
flush is unlikely enough getting it it
is okay with a hundred big blinds
you could still raise but probably not
go all-in to pair the board is sort of
scary but to pair is definitely good
enough here so all right so these are
examples where you had really good hands
and I said you should just raise and get
the money in and be happy about it so do
I need such a good hand there's some
other situations where a one pair hand
is sort of good enough and so coming
back to the jaw ace-jack example you
asked so we'll see some of that um okay
so in this case I think if you have
pocket aces and that's definitely good
enough to get it in although you
shouldn't have pocket aces that often
here because most of the time you
shouldn't be be raising preflop but you
know if you if you decide not to raise
pocket aces preflop and you end up with
it here then then I guess
bathing is good you're gonna be having
the better hand although you know if
you're trapping them preflop maybe you
just want to trap them again and call
again since there's not that many Syrian
Kurds so here's an example of an East
Jack situation where I think getting in
is fine just because there's still
drawers and there's still lots of worst
hands that would give you action but
overall your equity against their range
is much much higher on Jack seven deuce
ten Jack ten nine so I would just raise
and be happy getting in for you big
blinds here here's a similar example
King Jack but we've also got the
second-best flush draw so it's just very
hard to get it in batter
okay so we'll see some examples where we
have fewer chips so in the in the last
case out of the hands we essentially had
forty big blinds essentially had a lot
of chose so okay so now let's look at a
situation where all the players so we
only have 1250 to start the hand so
that's 25 big blinds and okay so in this
case even if you've got top hair with
the mediocre kicker I would just be
prepared to go all-in
because we were risking a lot fewer
chips we're risking a lot fewer chips
relative to the blinds so here I would
just go go all-in
so here are some yeses I'm showing you
some examples where do you know if I'm
40 or more big blinds deep I wouldn't be
happy getting all my money in but when
I'm only 25 big blinds deep I'm very
happy to get all my money in um
this is another example top here top
kick here it is a scary board in some
sense but there's just you just got a
gamble for it when when the pot is
already so big on the fog relative to
your stack same thing again here so
earlier I had some examples of this on
similar to this where I said you just
called but when you've only got when
you've only got four to five times the
flop let's start 45 times the 5 o'clock
I would just go for it ok I'll quickly
run through this session this is this
this section this is a slightly more
advanced play where where you don't
check to the
razor so this whole time I've been
talking about checking you the preflop
raiser as a form of respect respecting
that the preflop raisers range contains
aces and yours probably doesn't so when
do we want to lead so from a theoretical
point of view so from trying to play
optimally point of view essentially we
want to lead flocks that hit our range
ha better than his even though his range
contains aces which is like a universal
best hand so they're rare but they do
exist and I think it's okay if you've
never leave but I'm gonna quickly run
through this session this section
showing some examples or I think leading
is fun but I think it's an advanced
unnecessary play so okay so here's an
example
yeah I hope this is visible so we were
pretty shallow here so most of the
situation for leading is good you're a
fairly shallow so so I cut off two from
the other so one from the button makes
it 1,200 at 300 600 and there's antes so
we call with nine deuce suited with four
and a half to one odds okay so and so
here we flop two five six and I lead a
third of blah the third of pot planning
essentially to get only money because
we're so shallow like I only started the
hand with ten big blinds essentially any
pair is gonna be good enough to get
online money in although maybe not a few
days from under the gun but from from
cutoff I'm happy to put all my money in
against this so what's the rationale so
our hands good enough to put our money
in and it's essentially a better flop
for our range because we're sort enough
where the the immediate equity preflop
means so much to us that we're calling a
very wide range of hands basically a lot
of hands that includes change threes
fours fives and sixes whereas his range
he opened from button so he started he
opened from cutoff you know even though
it contains more monstrous and spinners
like pocket aces it also just contains a
lot of hands like jack tenon and queen
tang basically hands that don't connect
with this board because if he had six
five he probably isn't gonna open at
least
by recommendations he should be opening
65 whereas we can have hands like six
five we can have hands like four three
so I lead here so it's it's basically
essentially saying you know I'm no
longer respecting you because the flop
came in a very specific way we're now my
range of hands is actually better than
your range of hands so I'm essentially
the preflop aggressor I'm going to bet
and try to make the pot big and force
you into a tough situation with your
weaker range um and yeah we can play
play like this with our good hands and
with our bad hands like seven three we
have a book got chocolate we can we
couldn't Bluff with it so here's another
example so under the gun raises we call
with ace nine suited which i think is a
bit speculative but whatever we decided
call and we leave the ten seven five
o'clock where we have a flush draw a
nose once again I think it's reasonable
so it's it's deep it's fairly deep but
we can have even though big have aces we
can have more hands like we can have
more pocket fives pocket sevens take
hands than him who might not open those
and also he almost certainly isn't ever
gonna have nine eight of diamonds or
Jack nine of diamonds hands that are
basically he wants your straws whereas
we can so once again I bet because I
don't really want him to check back east
cane or pocket eights or something what
she probably will because you know if
they have ace king they're gonna think
the board is fairly scary they're
probably not gonna fold that much
because there's so many drawers if I bet
so they're just gonna check back east
King and that essentially has that
essentially has two problems is we're
not beating Ace King unless we improve
so by betting we basically we just make
the pot bigger against Ace King and
nines and we we can get them to fold
whereas if we check it might just get
shut down and yeah so so yeah one caveat
about leading though is if your opponent
knows leading as part of your strategy
then your range is
the weaker when you actually check so as
a result if your opponent knows you're
the type of player who let's say on uh
you know so this is really getting next
higher that's the next level but if they
know that you're the type of player he
will lead a lot of your hands on a two
five six slop in this specific situation
then when you check do them with a hand
like jack ten they can basically just
bet and know you'll almost certainly
fold because you're leading a lot of
your good hands so that's another copy
of caveat about leading it's um it's
very tricky balance correctly because
you need to you know if you're leading
Bluffs you need to also lead some good
hands to balance it out but then you
also need to check some good hands
occasionally to balance out all the bad
hands you're checking so that your
opponent can't just bet for free so it's
a very tricky player I wanted to quickly
run through it to you know to just say
it's out there and you know when you
watch poker and you see people not
automatically check to the preflop
aggressor sort of give you an idea of
why but it is a fairly advanced and
tricky play and it's easy to make
mistakes leading which is why I think
you know I think it's fine if throughout
this course you never lead okay so now
we're talking about some implied odds
and reverse implied odds so okay so
here's a situation so note that so we
have the worst hand in poker we got six
but we've only got three big ones okay
and hijack raises to 2,400 so the
question is do we want to do we want to
calm this situation so we're putting in
1600 so we can do a quick equity
calculation so if we call we're all-in
so the only thing that matters is the
equity of our hand against his range
that's essentially the only thing that
matters because he has no more decisions
so optimal play doesn't even matter in
this case it's a strict mathematical
expectation calculation and and we're
actually so you basically we need to
call two big blinds so sixteen hundred
that's two big lines to win how much is
already in the pot is a five and a half
right five and a half big blinds so they
made a big race if they made it they
made it 3x so we need to over seven
point five which is twenty seven
percent equity and if we put them on a
reasonable range from that position we
have 28 percent equity was enough people
so I think calling is a fine play okay
I'm not being in front of this person so
I think probably with me um so yeah
calling is a fine pipe and so now but I
want to emphasize okay so calling is a
good play because it's positive expected
expectancy why don't we call when we
have more chips so in this situation you
know if someone called they would
probably be ridiculed right why are you
calling with 2/7 off suit against a
hijack raise that isn't even give me
good odds because they based it 3x which
is a big raise
so why is it bad in this case when you
have more chips and the reason is
essentially what's called reverse
implied odds so in the first situation
we called because we were all in and the
equity calculation said we could but in
the second situation even though the
equity calculation is the same and we do
have the right odds to call preflop the
hand isn't over there is still
potentially 46,000 more chips to be put
in post flop and with a hand like seven
deuce off suit it's not only is it a
weekend it's very hard to be play when
we hit a pair we hit a small pair we're
often not going to be sure whether we
have the better hand we're gonna have to
decide whether to fold or call them down
and we're often gonna be wrong so it's a
very very easy fold in this situation
even though you have the odds because
these reverse implied odds hurt you so
much when there's still potentially
46,000 to play or postponed okay
so here let's say instead of 7/2 off
suit I had east to office ooh I would
still fold so if you do the same
chemical absolutely calculation we
actually have 43% against his range
which is tremendous but you only need to
27 percent equity chavalla to two all-in
right so why would we fold when we have
43 percent equity and we only need 27
percent equity because the reason is
because once again reversed implied odds
so they're usually actually be this way
you could cheat in online coder so they
have this thing called disconnect
protection which is if someone
disconnects this is really stupid I
thought I got cheated by this so many
times um basically if you disconnected
instead of your hand getting folded
essentially there's no more betting and
all the cards are dealt and the person
who like wins the hand is wins the pot
okay so essentially by disconnecting you
can say okay screw you there's no more
betting we're just gonna see until the
river and whoever wins the hand is gonna
win the hole so basically you could
cheat in this situation even if you had
72 offsuit by just calling and then
disconnecting immediately and then none
of this reverse implies a six but you
can't cheat like this anymore
yes so don't try to make that play so
yeah so in this case even though you
have 43 percent equity I would fold here
with nine eight suited it's a whole
different story we only have 37 percent
equity which is worse than 43% but I
would call what nine eight suited you
can make a flush and make a better hand
than em you can make you straight and
get him to put in a lot of money with a
good pair and yeah you're still out of
position you suck the ass act ii but
overall it's just a much better
situation okay so so now I want to talk
about it implied on so with the nine
eight suited you know I sort of talked
about its implied odds the fact that you
still have to play for more chips after
on the turnin river almost looking their
favorite because you can make straights
and flushes and have a very good hand
and be fairly certain your wedding and
get him to put in more money with the
worst hand so implied odds is basically
yeah it's when the odds are in your
favor because you're applying an hand
that plays well for Locke okay so okay
so let's look at adding example where
implied odds I think are good so this is
called set mining this is a play that's
I think so I'm gonna go through it even
though it's a play that's sort of dying
in poker I think it's a play that no
longer works that well in practice
nowadays at least at like at fairly high
stakes but it's in theory I think it
teaches you a very good thing about
those implied odds so in this case under
the gun raises do
yes 2,400 when the blinds are four
hundred eight hundred and we decide to
call so if you do the calculation we
don't have enough equity to call but why
do we call so essentially we're in
position because we have the button and
also we can win essentially a huge pot
when we hit a third deuce so now this
only happens a small percent of the time
if you do the calculation this happens
roughly 1/8 of the time you're going
ahead 1/3 deuce 1/8 of the time and
essentially when you don't hit a deuce
you're against and under the gun race so
he's gonna have a really strong range
you're gonna lose the pot 7/8 at the
time essentially roughly speaking so
what this is essentially saying is you
know if I only win in the pot 1/8 of the
time I need to win on average eight
times as much as I lose for it to be
worth it right but the point is at least
back in the day in poker you essentially
do because when you do hit the juice
they just they're gonna have pocket aces
or pocket kings or you know that folk
will come a 6 2 and the face came though
there's have a tremendously good end
that's still crushed by your hand so
often that you definitely essentially
1/8 of the time you lose 2,400 ships and
it's sorry 7/8 of the time you lose
2,500 chips and 1/8 of the time you win
their whole stack of 80,000 chips
essentially is how what the best
situation is so yeah so you need a lot
of chips for this to be a good play you
know even if you have 40 big blinds
which is by the harder standard is
fairly deep and it's still not that good
because once again you only win 1/8 of
the time so you really need to win a lot
when you win you win and like you know
when you hit it - it's not a hundred
percent sure that he's gonna put in all
his money so the fact so basically
you're only winning a huge pot even
lesser than 1/8 like you need to hit it
- a means that you have aces or kings so
you know that's that's gonna be like
120th or whatever but the point is if
the point is if the stack is so deep
then it's so
essentially and the reason why it's sort
of dying in poker is because I think you
know nowadays players are given up where
even if they have aces under the gun
certain they realize the optimal
strategy isn't you always put all your
money in on a 75 to flop but but but
yeah long story short I think this is a
fine play I think it's fine if you do it
in there currently because it's it's
tough to pull bases on a 75 deuce flop
and yeah I think it's a it's a good play
to know about at least so here's another
hand so come up raises to 2,000 we have
Jack ten suited on the button so once
again we don't have direct odds to call
but we have good implied odds because
we're in position and suited connected
hand okay so I'm going to go through the
whole hand because there's many more
examples of implied odds here so both
lines fold and they the preflop
aggressor the cut off continuation bets
about a bit less than half of pot and we
have a flush draw here so what is the
effective stack size even though we
started the hand with 80,000 they only
have they only started the hand of
30,000 so the effective stack size is
only 30,000 so we're definitely not
folding we could call or we could raise
the problem with raising is when we
raise and they go all-in
we're sort of in a really crappy
situation where our hands good to good
to really want to fold but - we do have
the odds to call us all in so so I think
just calling is the right play and yeah
raising gives him the opportunity to be
raised on if we call he he can't say L
it's right now and putting in more chips
right so okay so we miss on the turn
which kind of sucks and they bet fairly
big they bet 8,000 into 12,000 so let's
do into that bit let's do an analysis so
okay so a simplifying some assumption
let's assume they have it okay let's
assume we we model the most fairly tight
when they're making this bet they've got
a speed we're not gonna win the hand by
rivering a jacquard
we need to remember redundant so
essentially let's assume they just have
East King or they have it they're gonna
have a pair of aces at least so we need
to call it that was in to win 20,000 in
the pot so we need 8 over 28 or 29
percent equity and if you count there's
nine diamonds out of 46 cards so with so
we only have 20% equity and we need 29
percent equity but I would still call so
because when we call and we hit our
question we can actually weaken and
there's a decent chance that we're gonna
get called whereas if we call and we
miss our flush we can just happily fold
does that make sense everyone so we
don't really have the odds to call here
but we call because we can if we hit our
diamond we can go all-in on the river
and there's a decent chance they're
gonna call us and we're gonna win more
money so we actually do have the odds
essentially we have the implied odds
okay
so here's a similar scenario so pretend
the same thing happened but this was the
situations and in this case I think we
should we should definitely fold so what
changed was instead of having two
diamonds on the board and two diamonds
in our hand
now there's three diamonds on the board
and one diamond right so it's worse for
many many reasons so what is one is when
when you only have one diamond in your
hand and there's three diamonds on the
board the board if they have like Ace
King it's gonna be more obvious that we
probably have a flush if we bet on the
river and they have like Ace King so
there probably is gonna fall in ace king
so we're not gonna get paid off when we
hit the diamond and even worse we're not
even drawing you the best - the best
hand like what if they have ace came
with the King of Diamonds then we're
just crushed we're dying dead in this
situation there's no cards that can help
us win so that's just such a huge risk
so yeah and also a small thing but the
board is paired so it's possible they
have like pocket aces or a spy they
already have a full house and even if we
hit the best flush we're not gonna work
okay so okay so that was a good example
I think of when you had the implied odds
to call with your jobbies trying to hit
when you don't have
my trying to hit but we can also Bluff
withdraws so and all the examples I gave
you before where you check for AIDS the
flop we had a good hand right but
obviously this is predictable if they
know that we only check raise there
thought that what stupid or better they
can just fold whatever they have one
pair or worse right so draws not only
are they good for implied odds purposes
where you call and then only put in more
money when you hit they're also very
good for bluffing in certain situations
so so essentially what you'll realize is
bluffing is sort of equivalent to having
it drawn in some sense because the hands
you want to bluff with over the handset
have some draw value so here's an
example on the button raises to 1600 so
we're 20 big blinds deep and we're in
the big blind with 10 9 and we call with
our 4 point 5 to 1 odds okay and the
flop is jack 10 5 so we've got what I
would consider a good draw so a good
draw I would say usually means either an
open-ended straight draw so a four in a
row do a straight so there's eight
potential cards that complete your
straight or a flush draw which it
usually has ninety days okay and they
bet 2500 and then we go all-in in this
situation um essentially we're bluffing
we're hoping they fold but why is this a
good play so you know it seems pretty
same you just call instead ready because
we can call we can have perfect
information of when we hit where we
don't and only risk more money if we do
but it's actually also quite a good play
to go all-in because you know even
though it looks like we have a bad hand
to be risking all our chips these we
only have 10 high the point is the fact
that we have 10 high doesn't matter
because they're never calling are all in
with like a naked queen higher canine
right they're not going to call with a
random hand one so what matters isn't
how good our hand is in this case 10
high what matters is how many outs we
have against the hands that they call it
so in this case we're always going to
have 8 it's even if they have the best
possible handling
pocket jacks we're still gonna have the
he totes so this is a great handy bluff
with because if we call where we might
just lose the pot to like queen high by
the river whereas if we check raise all
in we're just it's essentially the
opposite of what I was talking about
before with like B being adversely
selected here it's just essentially
being been officially selected because
all the hands that barely meet you he's
gonna fold and if they have a hand as
good as Jeb when they have a hand as
good as Jack Jack it's almost it's
almost like wasted you know they have
they dr. Jack Jack with if they had Jack
Jack they're hoping we have like pocket
eights that only has one out against
them but here we have a much worse hand
in pocket eights with eight notes
against them
you can like contrast this with having
to say like six five on the spot six
five is a really bad hand you raise with
you just want to be calling because it's
sort of the opposite your any hand that
b2 is gonna be crushing you and you're
just going to fold out the hands that
are already losing to your six five
but yeah so six five if you're against
like East Jack you only have five outs
and you have close to 0% equity against
the pocket jacks so right so this is
eventually the bluffing epiphany so
waiter bluffing the when you're bluffing
before the river the thing that matters
isn't how good our hand with is its how
many outs we have okay so right okay so
this is essentially just me talking
about the the bluffing epiphany so you
want to always Bluff with hands that
have a high number of boats against the
hands that you get called by so here's
an example of something that's not
Walker okay so the cut off raises to 90
and we call with seven six of diamonds
on the big boy and this happens randomly
if sometimes you'll see someone make it
play like works and it's good you're
going to somehow make a play like this
and it's going to
and they're gonna look like a genius so
we checked through the preflop raiser
we've got nothing but we have a read
that they like scratcher here or
something so they're weak so we kept
Ray's hoping that they fold so we get
called and you know we've still got
absolutely nothing here and we bet on
the turn because that's the only way we
could potentially win the hand and they
call and then we still have nothing and
as a last resort we go all-in on the
river and you know a good percent of the
time they're gonna fold and Morgan look
like a genius for making this block
right so basically this is not so yeah
this is not bluffing this is essentially
like opening your wallet and giving you
so when when you're yeah when your check
racing you essentially the reason why
you were check raising in the first
place as a bluff is because you had some
chance of making a good hand and
essentially a bluff is because you're
the the hand that you could have
potentially made the flush that you
potentially gonna mean didn't get it's
not because you started with a hand that
you could never make anything on this
board and it didn't get there so okay so
here's a so here's a similar situation
where I think makes a lot more sense so
it's gonna be similar board but we have
1090 parts and here we check raise their
flop they're fought bet so this
situation is a bit different than the
Jack of Diamonds situation from a while
ago where we only called with the flush
draw the reason why it raising here is
better is because the stack sizes is
deeper so with the Jack 10 of diamonds
hand the problem with check raising was
there's a risk they would go all-in and
we would fold because we don't have good
enough Ott's yet our hand is so good
here are heinous similarly good but
because it's so shallow because it's so
deep so we actually started the hand
with uh with I think a hundred big
blinds instead of 40 big blinds
they're pretty unlikely to go all so
here Chuck raising as a check raising
ten out of Hertz has a lot lower chance
of getting blown off and okay we get
called
and we turned 15 outdraw so we had nine
outs here right
but the jack now essentially uses 50
notes because it gives us the eight
open-ended straight notes plus the nine
flush outs - the - from double counting
so 50 notes and we bet 650 here so it's
the same it's the same hand as a 76 suit
it's the same hand as the stupid play um
we're betting here and we get called so
some notes here our hand was good enough
where you know even though when we bet
650 into the pot on this turn they could
go on if they have like East Jack
they're probably gonna go all-in and you
know it's going to suck but that's we
have good enough odds in this case in
this case because we have so many outs
that we can even call an all-in so it's
it's funny we can just call and yeah so
note that by check raising the flop
betting turn so the good thing about
playing draws like this is that now if
we play jobs like this we can also get
play our good hands like AC or pocket
deuces like this and get paid off a lot
more so okay so we get called and then
the river is a king it's not the
scariest card but you know we we met we
need ten of Hearts we could easily have
a queen ten of Hearts so we go all in
here and you know even if the King
wasn't scary at all like even if the
king was like a three or a juice I'm
fine it's just going all in because
that's the only way we can win the hand
but it's a fine excuse here to go all in
with ten high on the river and say that
is the only way I put him on the hand
because there was a reason I was check
raising and representing all the
strength on the flopping turn right it's
because I had a heart drop my heart
didn't get there so now I need you
desperately do have a chance of winning
the hand go all-in but it's it's um it's
reasonable the reason why I got to this
situation this bad situation is because
essentially I'm lucky right I had a
chance of hitting a flush and I didn't
it's not like the seven six case where I
knew I was going to get it
situation which is not a good situation
but here I got a bit unlikely to get
into situation okay
so this is the last example so last
example when you when you give up on a
block so sometimes you know you're
bluffing you don't have a great hand but
sometimes you just give up because
you've figured out your opponents not
folding or like the board comes out in a
way where it's not theoretically a good
idea for the opponent to fold so hijack
minus one makes 90 cutoff calls and
we're 100 bets teeth we call it Jack
nine of Hearts from the big body okay so
the flop is ten seven deuce and so we
have we get a decent flop so once again
you know we have we have a reasonable
draw here we have some reason to be
bluffing we don't have nothing we have
some reason to people I think because
even though based essentially we're
hoping to turn eight even though the
chance of that is only four out of forty
seven which is low it's but it's still
something and it's much better to bluff
with a four out of 47 chance of making a
monster hand than a zero out of 47
chance so okay so here this was
interesting the preflop aggressor
checked which is fine as the preflop
aggressor you're not forced to bet the
flop so but this but note but note that
the preflop aggressor is not the guy he
bet the flop so the cut off bets the
flop but the cut off was not the preflop
aggressive okay so come up shouldn't
have pocket aces they could occasionally
but it's less likely than usual that
they have pocket aces so they bet and we
decide to check race here and yeah I
think this is a very reasonable play so
what are the reasons one so yeah we have
something we can try to we can try to
turn in eight and also you know turning
a jack is fine we can also turn a heart
and so we have lots of backdoor draws we
could turn a heart that'll give us four
hearts we could turn even like a queen
or give us an open-ended straight draw a
key will also give us an open-ended
straight draw so that's the weird case
where so if the turn is a
King then the board will be king 10:7
and will have a back nine and then an
eighth or a queen will give us a
straight it's one of the rare cases it's
called it's called a double gunshot or a
double gutter so it's one of them we're
it's one of the strange cases to watch
out for it's possible to have an eight
straight draw even though you don't have
four do a straight so one example is
where you have like where it's like this
one where you have a king and inject in
nine and then seven and another example
is where let's say you have like King
Jack on an East ten seven six board then
essentially essentially it's East King
Blanc Jack ten Blanc eight seven so then
you can have a hit a nine or a queen so
there's a couple of weird straight draws
again but anyways the point is so yeah I
think this is a good play not only
because we have a crappy hand that's
basically so basically a crappy draw is
a really intended glove with but also
the fact that their range isn't
particularly strong here because they
can't really have it aces so the I mean
they can have pocket sevens or pocket
deuces I guess but also we're attacking
the fact that he's not the preflop
raiser so they're their range isn't that
strong okay so so hijack minus 1 the
preflop aggressor gets out of the way
and cut off calls us and then the turn
is a 7 which is basically the worst card
in the deck for us I'd say the 7 of
clubs even if it was like the 7 of
spades it wouldn't be better um so so
why is this the worst card so first of
all it doesn't help us at all right it
doesn't give us any kind of better
straight draw or better flush draw or a
pair and further them all it's fairly
it's it's fairly safe you know even if
even if the turn was an ace we could at
least pretend we have a pace the 7 is a
fairly safe card if they have a pair of
10s they're not jeopardized because in a
scheme furthermore the main issue is his
range is gonna be a lot more likely to
contain a7 than RH because remember what
I said earlier you don't really want to
be raising
check raising the flop with your middle
the road pants because you're middle of
the road hands you want to just call
because when you raise you're getting
called live worse sorry you're getting
called by better and you're folding out
worse so probably if I had a seven on
the flop here I'm never checked raising
so basically I can't have a seven here
and and furthermore they're a lot more
likely you have a seven so this just
really hurts us essentially it's just a
bad situation where their range is a lot
stronger than our range and basically
the best thing we can do is just fold
our hand there's no point you know
there's no point to try to continue
bluffing like it's sort of like playing
this huge taller game where you don't
get to see my height but you know that I
was like malnourished as a kid but you
just know on average there's no way I'm
gonna be tolerated so the right thing to
do here is just saw a wall and it was
like the worst start that can but we
just give up the hand which is fine and
then and then they take down [ __ ] right
so bluffing epiphany 2 is basically
other than counting how many outs we
have is important to analyze what we're
representing what else is in our range
you know we're bluffing we don't have a
good hand but what's the good hand that
we could potentially have in some other
parallel universes that were
representing and in this case there just
really isn't anything so yeah so like
eastern would have been fine even a
six-term would have been okay cuz we
better represented nine eight so one of
the best times to Bluff is when you're
drawn is but a different draw completed
so like if you had a straight draw and
you were bluffing the flop and then the
tremor completes the flush it's
reasonable to bet I mean you do run into
the risk that they have the flush but
also it's just they're gonna be more
scared as flush and similarly yeah like
if you have a if you have a flush draw
and they're straight completes you go so
bad okay so yeah so right there are a
lot of poker concepts today so that's
the end I'll give a quick summary so
hopefully this will give hopefully this
will give people more ideas on how to
play online I know I sort of left you
guys in the dark
last time I mean I've ran through things
pretty quickly this hopefully you know
as you play more it's okay if you didn't
understand everything immediately but
hopefully as you play more
you'll be like I implied odds or you'll
be reminded of examples from this class
so yeah so we covered continuation
betting the preflop aggressor getting
the respect being able to bet the
fundamental theorem of poker about how
you get your good hands and bluff your
bad hands we analyze different flops and
I try to give you a general idea of what
sorts of how good your hand needs to be
observing the kinds of flops and yeah so
when I showed you the different flops
you know what I told you I didn't like
mathematically proved that calling is go
to raising is good it's basically just
like from experience and from doing
calculations
I know roughly your equity is good
enough but I didn't like mathematically
prove it so you essentially just have to
trust me in that sense for the example
of flops and I showed you because I
didn't show any calculations yeah we
talked about when you lead we have to
imply dog for Bruce and fly dives set
mining bluffing withdraws and then the
two bluffing epiphanies and yeah so it's
important to so basically it's much
easier to play good hands than bad hands
in poker and some sense to use when you
have a good hand you just bet and hope
you're going calls but it's important to
know how to play bad hands
aka Bluff so that your opponent also
might call you when you have a good hand
because if you're the type of player to
never Bluffs then the game is
uninteresting right so because then your
opponent just always flows whenever you
do anything so that's why it's important
to think about the whole thing Epiphanes
okay cool yeah thanks and hope you
continue to play online